qui est qui quand il était petit avant
qu'il ne s'endorme je raconte est
toujours la même histoire à mon fils de
la philosophie
non monsieur pourquoi monter vous êtes
enfin monsieur je ne mens pas je raconte
des histoires
[Musique]
alors marines palmyre bonsoir tu as
toujours travailler au noir toi un petit
moulin
j'ai toujours fait un peu ce que j'ai
voulu mais c'est un indépendant car
j'étais un peu comme les oiseaux qui
nous coûtent pas sur son courage a été
danseur dont était dans son mandat c'est
à dire j'ai eu des propositions pour
monter à paris pour lancer
bon j'ai eu des propositions c'est qu'à
cette affaire en compte toutes sortes de
gens et dieu sait si j'en ai connu boxer
ou de voeux présentés aussi un vrai
outil ancien champion du monde après
pour chanter j'avais il ya un gars nîmes
qui voulait me présenter un imprésario à
marseille n'ont jamais rien pris au
sérieux
c'était fou chaleur souris de qualité un
léger mieux péter fuller cgt footballeur
c'est juste que tu es sur tous ces
champions de boule provençale et où ils
sont simplement d'adapter comme un siège
aux bulls est spécialisée dans
j'ai gagné howell iii 5 concours vient
de partout au départ on tenait un bal
saper le bal pas venir c'était où ça
c'est la citadelle propre et c'est vrai
qu'à mistinguett maurice chevalier
qu'ils sont produire avant d'aller avant
de faire quelques pillages cette affaire
- qui confère un jour
je crois qu'ils devraient faire une
balade mais avec quoi qu'elle en est qu
à l époque et alors il a commencé à
dégager la piste
et puis la coupure et ouais alex mairie
à chaque achat pour un et après par la
suite nous avait baptisé sa la cage à
poules face à monthey n'a pas encore
gagné
non je les paye majorité c'est devenu
fois maintenant alors le bal valmy
rungis et passe pas c'est dommage qu'ils
aient pas de continuer ce que nous
faisions nous parce que nous à l'époque
on aurait tapé sur des casseroles que
les gens venaient ouais parce qu'il y
avait une ambiance un y avait des comics
et intel est plutôt sobre d'individus y
avait des voyous y avait des gens bien
mais les poids lourds y avait tout ce
qu'on voulait surtout démarrage mais
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une américaine
qui adorait danser avec toi alors et qui
voulait amener à cincy natixis de 7 et
une femme qui quitte la jeune chien
parce que c'est les fans un jeu car je
danse je suis arrivé à gênés et
jamais à l'américain tout pour moi elle
avait demandé un départ en martinique à
la cinat et pourquoi t'es pas partie je
n'ai jamais pu mettre à l'essai ont pas
autorisés
ouais mais c'est vrai qu'un jeu il ya un
homosexuel qui a voulu t'acheter un
hasard où il s'affiche dans cette
histoire c'est à dire je plaisais
beaucoup à ces messieurs 1
et celui ci aussi voulait m'emmener en
amérique avant à tout prix avaient alors
été embrassée sur la bouche
ah non mais ça c'est un autre c'est
notre gars un bon c'est un jeune mec est
tellement sympa j'avais le plateau dans
les mains comme ça un détenu par
derrière ou fera à l'addition pourrait
être celui-là salé l'addition en bref
voilà il était sympa ouais c'est vrai
qu'il ya une soixantaine d'années saint
tropez c'était un petit chicago et que
ouais qu'est ce qui se passait à
saint-tropez var il se passait que
d'abord c'est et un port marchand il y
avait trois un genre qui de gens de
toutes nationalités quoi est elle est
surtout des bagarres ou des bagarres
alors ils finissent mal
il n'y avait pas de lien et pas de
policier va enchanter par un vous sentez
pas parce que vous avez le trac
et puis c'était des hommes étaient très
costauds très méchant est ensuite très
queer
il aurait pris une bouteille je ne
m'attends arriver là oui mais vous avez
fait ce qu'il fallait c'était comme ça
qu'ils s'étaient pas d'erreur c'est ton
père était obligé de sortir le nerf de
boeuf ont fait c'est une affaire très
difficile à tenir
il y avait les ouailles aux gars étaient
vraiment et les méchants c'est vrai
pendant la guerre c'est gagner un peu
d'argent je sais ce fait j'ai fait ce
que nous pouvons essayer un peu de noir
ne vendais quoi je donne déficit c'est à
dire je dépannais plutôt les gens
aimeraient que je faisais pas tellement
pour l'argent on en débat dès les cartes
de père m'a demandé il ya eu des troupes
américaines que débarque alors là il y
avait de la marchandise y en avait un
peu de cigarettes ou y avait de tout le
tout ils ont demandé sa part camion 1 ce
qui avait de la place pour gary et par
camion n'a pas été résistant non mais
j'ai fait des trucs au débarquement que
les résistances aux dix ans je les
voyais tous planqué sous les ponts parce
qu'ils avaient peur et moi j'étais
partout j'en ramassais une mitraillette
venait de tomber du ciel
et j'ai failli me tuer moi j'appelle
cela qui va souvent la pêche c'est à
dire là c'est autre chose le bateau est
une histoire c'est aussi ça a été le 40%
de malice un bateau ça a été j'ai fait
des rencontres la sensationnelle
si je vous disais les gens que j'ai eu
d'abord chez payot livre de bord j'ai eu
et tous les bras droit de deux vols
vaquer vichot grands décorateurs partie
de cinéma pour le mil et victor
madeleine renaud jean louis barrault la
marseillaise qui a épousé main de fer
qui avait gagné
comment s'appelle le monde et demande de
charles main le site aurait des
centaines d'errol flynn
non non et re finement abord rôles fine
c'est le premier qui m'a pris nos photos
en couleurs à pampelonne au début des
appareils quand il sortait déjà l'été
des coûts le monde venait avec son
bateau les acca la saga avec son
équipage de noir et un beau bateau qui a
vraiment découvert synphot paie toi tu y
étais là dès le départ c'est à dire sans
me tromper mais par en larmes cette
affaire toute la jeunesse de saint
tropez avec les gens de mon âge ont tous
appris à danser chef du ce était déjà et
puis c'était très côté d'un côté il ya
les pincer lendemain savons guère le
début on était tous chez nous et c'était
un peu qu'ils ont un peu quand on parle
de brigitte bardot s'est séparé vous pas
qu'il est
quelque chose mais ça lui a fait il ya
toujours eu les
peu de monde gens très bien et
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu penses de
ce qu'est devenu saint tropez quelque
chose autre chose c'est un peu foutraque
c1
avant les gens voyez les gens bien aimé
par exemple pour côtoyer les gens du
pays
vraiment j'ai vu mon jeune âge et chez
vous pas plaisir parce que c'est le
genre qui on avait des cadillac plus
alors on est ramené des fois il est
demandé de les conduire à l'autel vous
allez petit peu éméché et il vous
reviendra cardiaque chez vous un peu
leur une soupe de poisson en échange non
on était bien servir un il ya des gens
comme sa fin aujourd'hui c'est fini tout
ça
non non c'est peut-être pas pu parce que
dans la poule il ya peut-être encore des
gens comme c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de les trouver et les temps ne faut pas
qu'ils veulent beaucoup quand même en ce
moment vient au mois qu'on attend la
pluie
aussi faut s'attendre ce soir et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu